(dance music)
- This is The Super Late Morning
Show, we're the Lucas bros.
I'm Kenny, this is Keith.
Yo, it's time for the weather, man.
- So let's just go to Mookie
and see what it's like.
(soaring intense music)
(bubbling)
- Oh!
Hey.
It's mad sunny out today.
(soaring intense music)
- Today, we're honoring real dads, man.
- Yeah, man, real dads that
make real choices, man.
We'll be honoring deadbeat fathers.
- [Kenny] Yes.
(gentle acoustic guitar)
Yeah, so, I think a lot of people get mad
at deadbeat fathers
for leaving their kids.
I think it's great.
- Yeah, man.
- You know what I mean?
- It's awesome, I think.
So, we brought one here.
- All right, we got a real
father just like our dad.
We got Brian coming out here.
Can we get Brian?
- Let's get Brian, give
him a round of applause.
(applauding)
- Brian, Brian, what's up, man?
How's it going, man, how's it going?
- Everything's going good for me.
(laughing)
- How's your kids,
how's your kids?
- I do not know.
- You live with that.
- I am, yeah.
- You made some tough choices.
- I made some tough choices, man.
- Yeah, man.
- I put people in the taxi pregnant.
- Did you even get into the taxi?
- I don't like taxis.
- Do you even, like, know
where your son was born?
Do you have any idea?
- At the hospital.
- [Kenny] Oh, okay.
(laughing)
- Definitely a hospital, right?
- Or a taxi, I don't know.
- So you weren't there,
what were you doing in place of that?
- I was on the block, man.
I have to make money.
I mean, I ain't got time
to be sitting around
cutting umbilical cords and all of that.
- That's fucking, that's beautiful.
- See, now you can't be a dad
if you're such a good drug
dealer, I get it, man.
- I mean, you know,
priorities, you gotta--
- Yeah, it's drug deal, and then, child.
(laughing)
- I mean, baby, I damn did my life.
You'd do the same thing.
- We got a prize for your
for coming on our show.
- Well, that's what's up!
- We're very grateful.
We actually got some tickets
for you and your sons to Disneyland.
- Bring out Johnny!
- What?
(applauding and heartfelt music)
- I got to go.
- We're just kidding,
man, Johnny's not here.
(laughing)
- Man, y'all got me.
Man.
- Nah, actually, man, you
got the greatest prize, man.
You got freedom, man.
- Freedom.
- That's what I mean.
- It's a beautiful thing.
- Thank you, Brian.
- Don't tell nobody I was here.
(laughing)
(soaring intense music)
- On Monday, we're
gonna have some sunshine
in the afternoon, leading in some clouds.
We give it a 10 out of
10 for smoking weed.
Tuesday, Wednesday, there's gonna be
some isolated T-storms
up in the northwest.
We're gonna give it a 10
out of 10 for smoking weed.
Thursday, little more rain, 10 out of 10.
Friday, it's gonna be back
to the sunshine, guys.
But my parents are gonna be in town,
so I'm giving it a 9 out
of 10 for smoking weed.
But for all you out there,
still gonna be a 10 out of 10 day.
(dance music)
(hip hop beat)
(baby crying)